[Musique]
noël le graet réagi suite à la polémique
du
boussoufa qui s'exprime dans le parisien
aujourd'hui en france
le président de la fédération française
de football affirme ce n'est pas ligne
des bleus je ne sais pas qui l'a appelé
pour faire à nîmes
vu que c'est pas un rappeur il n'est pas
dans le top ça fait longtemps qu'il n'a
rien fait d'extraordinaire donc il en
chanson n'est pas terrible du tout
évidemment ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui fait la sélection des chansons et
des musiques
à partir de là il ya une confiance qui
est fait à la fédération française de
football à l'équipe de france beaucoup
youssoupha je suis même allé à des
concerts de youssoupha et je me suis
fait porter le texte de la chanson c'est
un hymne aux bleus et moi le leem de
youssou phone me gêne absolument ça leur
pose aucun problème de soutenir
quelqu'un qui a des propos racistes qui
a des propos sexistes
c'est lui qui dit jeu ni scénique et
condescendant je suis l'ennemie de la
république tout cas ça vous choque ses
propos est ce que vous avez entendu un
membre du gouvernement ou de la majorité
soutenir les propos que vous avez
évoquées qui ne sont par ailleurs pas
des propos qui sont présents dans l'île
dont on parle mais des propos dans
d'autres chances mais j'attends quand
les condamne mais c'est ça a été le cas
de roxana maracineanu elle a dit elle
même que ça l'a choqué les propos qui
lui étaient présentés sur une femme moi
quand j'ai eu l'occasion d'être
interrogé sur le sujet j'ai dit la même
chose je reviens parce que je trouve que
l'état du pays est tellement beau jeu
était mis à peu en retrait mais je bien
sûr je suivais ça de très près parce que
ça m'a toujours passionné et c'est vrai
que l'état du pays mais est tellement
désespérant que je pense que tout le
monde doit s'engager
moi je prends mentionnant c'est comme
des nazis pour moi pour moi je le vois
comme ça c'est mon avis et va très vite
le pen n'avait pas l'impression sa fille
c'est le sens commande et torturer les
algériens jean-marie sa maîtresse lui
avait interdit qu'on s'asseye devant
derrière droite et à gauche de petite
fille de 10 ans qui était tout seul avec
personnes autour d'elle
donc ça ça forge c'est fou ça quand on
accuse marine de vouloir discriminer les
gens
en termes de discrimination et
d'injustice je peux vous dire qu'on en a
tellement vu que l is culminera jamais
personne interpellée à l'assemblée
nationale vous étiez présente chez le
député fauvergue
j'ai dit au fond que l'émotion ne
justifiait pas mais pouvait expliquer un
certain nombre de débours de hbo qui
m'ont déplu
le ministre de l'intérieur qui avait
invité son homologue de la justice eric
dupond moretti a rencontré les syndicats
de police dans le cadre du beauvau de la
sécurité pour moi la police et la
justice entend plus les relations entre
les deux ministres ce n'est pas un duel
c'est un duo c'est un binôme ans est en
élection départementale
chacun voit ce que c'est qu'un binôme
ces deux personnes qui ensemble vont
dans la même direction
ensemble emmanuel macron et son
homologue rwandais paul kagamé souhaite
écrire une nouvelle page dans la
relation entre leurs deux pays
la france a une responsabilité et c'est
cette responsabilité qu'il faut
reconnaître qu'il faut reconnaître c'est
pourquoi on a besoin de demander pardon
il doit au nom de la france présenté des
excuses oui aux victimes du génocide
savait il doit surtout dire la vérité
pendant 27 ans la france a vécu dans un
grand mensonge d'état
il ya eu beaucoup de crimes au 20e
siècle
mais là nous parlons de quelque chose
qui est probablement le plus grand crime
du 20e siècle
à 20 ans je me suis retrouvé à déterrer
des cadavres dans une fosse septique à
kigali et j'ai encore sur moi j'ai
encore sur moi cette odeur des cadavres
en putréfaction devient reconnaître nos
responsabilités une responsabilité
politique grave on fonctionnement
d'institutions il ya des questions qui
se posent pourquoi ce soutien et mon
continue un régime quand on savait ce
qu'il était et qui étaient ensuite
génocidaire même quand vous êtes battus
avec charisme vous avez été arrêté du
fait de la prison était bien remis en
prison même là votre mère elle était ok
ok mais d'affaires tabac ce que celui
qui me tabasser